NC: Oh, what's this, kids?
Oh, this is another excuse to weird stuff again, isn't it?
Well, your last excuse did result in Beetlejuice
and that was a big critical and box-office hit.
OK, you can take the rest of the day doing another one!
Those bunch of scamps.
This is another excuse to do weird stuff again, isn't it?
OK, look, the last time you did this, you made "Little Monsters,"
and that wasn't nearly as good.
So I want you to try a lot harder this time, OK?
I'm sure they'll get it this time around.
OK, look, your last film was "Cool World."
"Cool World!"
There's only so many times you can use this excuse
for doing weird stuff
just for the sake of doing weird stuff!
I'm giving you one more chance.
If this next one isn't as nearly as good as Beetlejuice,
you're both in big trouble!
Alright?!
Get out of my sight.
Tamara: Did you enjoy "Monkeybone?"
Malcolm and Tamara: I will not breathe.
I will not breathe.
NC: Well, how can you accomplish that if you're saying it?
*Both of them breath in*
NC: Hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic. I remember it so you don't have to.
Sometimes we like to give into the dark and weird
simply because it's dark and weird.
Some directors are so good at creating them
that it's how they make their living.
Giving us visually goofy, oddly nonsensical,
yet somehow massively entertaining madness.
But there's a right way and a wrong way to do it.
And after a while, the novelty of the strange wears off
and we see what still holds up and what doesn't.
Films like "Gremlins," "Addams Family," and "Paranorman" still hold up.
Films like "Monkeybone," "Monkeybone," and "Monkeybone" do not.
It's hard to say why some of these other weird work,
But it's very easy to see why this weird film doesn't.
Despite it being visually stunning and surreal,
it's annoying as balls!
It's loud.
It's stupid.
It's a good thing the director did these films because,
much like a trippy coma,
I don't know how far I can go before I couldn't come back!
So why's this the one that killed the weird and dark movies for a while?
Let's take a look with "Monkeybone."
Child: It was 3rd grade.
You know how some teachers have those flaps on their arms?
I began to feel...
aroused.
NC: Instantly sold!
Child: There he was!
Monkeybone!
NC: I'm so glad Cartoon Network finally greenlit
"An R. Crumb Christmas."
Though I'm surprised the title wasn't "Merry Crumbmass" or "Beware the Crumbus."
Hoestly I'm not even really joking.
This is a new kids' show that's going to hit television
called "Monkeybone."
And isn't this just the audience
you would expect applauding a show like this?
Move over Samantha, our new "Sex and the City" is "Monkeybone."
Look at this, there's even tons of kids' merchandise.
They're that certain it's gonna be a hit.
Merch Guy: Every kid's gonna want three
and they're gonna want their friends to have three
otherwise they're not gonna be friends anymore.
NC: Ugh
Yeah.
For this:
Kid: I began to feel aroused.
You have no idea how excited
kids are to see what "Duckman giving up looks like!
You know, aside from
the first time.
The human representation of the 90's
trying to die in the 2000's trying to begin-
or as you call him, David Foley-
addresses the crowd and introduces the creator
of the comic strip the show is based on,
Stu Miley.
Played by Brendan Fraser-
He did not draw that!
You lying sack of suck!
He did not come up with ANY of what we just saw!
Malcolm: Oh come on. There's usually good looking characters
in these weird dark films.
Tamara: Yeah. Why doesn't it work here?
NC: Sileeence!
Malcolm: Ow.
NC: In all those other films,
the main character was quirky, but still normal!
The grounding reality to offset the strangeness
that the rest of the film is about to throw at you.
But Fraser is already supposed to be weird and awkward and tormented.
The crazy geek behind the odd cartoons.
Tell me if even for a nanosecond you believe he's that kind of guy!
Stu: The cool thing is that you open it,
you go out, it closes and you can't get back in.
Malcolm: Okay.
Tamara: Yeah he's pretty bad.
NC: No no no.  He's so believable!
Just look at his chiseled, smiling, action hero demeanor
that SO represents the shy artist!
Malcolm: Alright!
Tamara: We get it!
I mean, not since Woody Allen or Paul Giamatti
have I so bought the introverted, uncomfortable, social outcast this much!
Stu: Look at this now!  He won't let us leave.
Julie: Who?
Stu: The monkey!
Julie: The monkey is good luck.
Stu: I never had any good luck.
Malcolm: We get it!
Tamara: We won't choose someone like him ever again!
NC: And what did we say about BREATHING!
*Both take deep breath*
He's about to propose to his girlfriend, played by Bridget Fonda,
Again, representing the "weirdo loser who gets lost in his own awkwardness."
Tamara: We said we're sorry!
NC: BREATHING!
And he tries to get her to leave the place.
Because, you know, "this social stuff is so hard on him."
He's totally gonna bench less if he talks anymore.
Oh I mean, in between his weird cartooning.
Julie: Stu, you want to leave? You're a big hit! Everbody loves you!
NC: Okay, advice by the way:
Don't have a background that's more interesting than your foreground.
Like most of you, I'm not listening to a thing they're saying and instead trying to figure out
what episode of "The Simpsons" that Krusty frame is from.
I know I've seen that one before.
Is it after season 7. I stopped watching after season 7...
I-I mean I watched, but you know,
it wasn't as good it was when it started to go down hill.
I mean okay, it never officially jumped the shark at any moment.
I don't know. The one with the fake Skinner,
that kinda jumped the shark.
That was pretty bad but- DAMMIT I'M STILL REVIEWING "MONKEYBONE!"
But one of the pieces of merchandise,
a...
giant inflatable raft,
"Pfft!  That overused market?
I thought they yanked those after people were disturbed sitting on Dora's face."
-goes off, and sends their car crashing into a wall.
Fraser is sent into a coma while Fonda is...
completely untouched!
Their car was a giant airbag, how was he knocked out?!
As Fraser enacts a vision he'll soon become familiar with:
watching himself die.
(statue singing)
Oh boy, you're not gonna take that background
overshadowing the foreground advice are you?
(singing to "This is Halloween")
"Boys and girls of every age,"
"Think our designers were overly paid."
Cyclops...thing: Hey bud!  Glad to see me?
NC: O-kay movie, I'll make a deal with you.
Nix all the actors
and just leave a 360 camera in the middle of the set,
I'll call it even!
Yeah, for all it's faults, this world is pretty damn amazing.
This place is called "Down Town."
Where people go when they're in comas
that's apparently run on people's nightmares.
And apparently everyone watched the same episode of Japan's "Pee-wee's Playhouse"
to come up with these images.
While it is a marvel for the eyes, it's a "DC" for the rest of the senses.
As Fraser comes across his creation, Monkeybone.
Voiced by a sped up John Turturro.
Monkeybone: Now I know you're all in comas.  But my first guess is gonna
SPIKE
YOUR
CHARTS!
NC: What's the difference in speeding up Turturro's voice, and
really anybody's voice to sound exactly the same?
Turturro costs more!
And trust me, casting a big name actor to do the voice doesn't distract how balls gratingly annoying he is!
Monkeybone: Homebone!
The lady got a loose caboose!
Homebone!
Get on the Julie train.
NC: Okay, I'm over the novelty of him being stop motion.
Now I hate him.
Monkeybone: I wanna be loved by you.
NC: "Anyone else created to work out the sexual issues of the director and/or writer?
Oh thank God, it's not just me.
So Fraser's sister, played by Megan Mullally, wants to pull the plug on him.
Why?
No.  That's not figurative.
I'm actually asking you why.
You probably have as much understanding as I do.
As far as I can tell, she just wants to kill him
and there's no motivation the film gives as to why.
I mean, okay, she says they made a pact because their father died so slowly,
but she seems way too excited and eager!
I don't really get it!
Kimmy (played by Mullally): Doctor!  Hey, sweetheart.
Which one's the plug?
Doctor: What plug?
Kimmy: The plug.
Malcolm: But it's dark so it's funny.
NC: Yeah it's dark,
but it's only funny if we understand why.
This is the first time we've seen her.
We don't know what they're relationship is like,
or even what SHE'S like
because we don't know why she's acting this way
or if this is how she normally acts or what?
There's no context!
Tamara: Yeah, but we blackmailed Bridget Fonda into being in this,
that's gotta count for-
okay.
NC: The doctor says that after three months,
it's less likely someone will come back from a coma.
So three months pass as shown by...
this dissolve.
I thought of that like more of a two and a half month dissolve,
but I still got the general passage of time.
As Fraser continues to train for how to not be funny in "Loony Tunes Back in Action."
Stu: You have humiliated me in public for the last time!
Monkeybone: I doubt that.
Stu: Back in the pack!
NC: You know, I'm just gonna say it.
What's the appeal of this guy?
I mean I know he's good looking and he played the likable doofus okay,
but looking back on his work, I can't say he's awful, but,
I can't really say he's good either.
Just look at this scene where he's supposed to act like Monkeybone is in front of him.
Stu: That's it, back in the pack.
NC: I think Brendan Fraser is the less convincing puppet.
Does it ever seem like he's looking at this thing?
Even when he's acting with other actors, it just seems like "George of the Jungle" light.
Stu: He got an exit pass! Where's mine? When do I get to go home?
NC: He gives the performance a million other actors could give.
It never seems distinctly unique.
Stu (blandly): Who am I kidding?
I'm never gonna get out of here.
NC: To his credit though, I don't know if any actor can make scenes like this work.
*A-OOGA! A-OOGA! DIVE DIVE DIVE
DIVE DIIIIIVE!*
Ah, the days when adult humor in animation was a novelty.
"A monkey jumping in a woman's boobs?
But those are cartoons!
Those things are for children!"
"Aren't they?"
Their antics are interrupted though, when one of the people in a coma is sent back to the living.
"Obie Glenn. I have come."
NC: "I'm the ghost of Christmas missteps.  I'm her to convince Michael Caine he can act with muppets.
The man is sent back to the real world through the mouth of Abraham Lincoln.
Because...
Because...?
Malcolm: Well you didn't think of it!
Tamara: So it's clever!
Malcolm: Yeah.
NC: Come here.
Did you know that if your knuckles are pink, you're more likely to be a genius?
Tamara: Well played.
NC: Get back there.
Fraser wants to figure out how he can get an exit pass,
so he goes to a pajama party of Hypnos,
the lord of dreams who loves the nightmares Fraser comes up with.
Again if the story could just politely leave and we can play a Rammstein song over this,
I think we could have something.
But the film insists it has a narrative, as Hypnos tells Fraser where to get an exit pass.
Monkeybone: No life support?  Ha ha ha ha.
Hypnos: I'm just the god of sleep.
This is death's bailiwick.
Monkeybone: Anybody got thumb(?) DESERVES TO DIE.
NC: Could you please shut up your Roger Rabbit?
I know he has a name, but it's just your Roger Rabbit.
Hypno says if he travels to the land of the dead,
he can steal an exit pass for himself,
but Fonda's convinced he's still in there trying to get out.
Julie: does anybody know what Oneirix is?
guy: It's nightmare juice.
You thinking we can decrease the levels?
Julie: No I want to give him more, I want to give him a massive dose.
I want to scare him awake!
You want to scare him awake, show him the reviews for "Single White Female."
But, in all seriousness, you are a treasure.
What are you doing in this movie?
Fraser disguises himself as a wicker tampon and sneaks in to see the Grim Reaper,
played by Whoopi Goldberg,
and her assistant,
played by Thomas Haden Church.
Reaper: I'm yours.  What do you want?
Reaper's assistant: Let's get to reapin'
NC: "We're the paycheck in between two big things."
They steal the exit pass, resulting in...
...Whoopi's head exploding...
Thank you.
Stu: It's just that, now that I'm leaving,
there's so many things I want to say to you.
NC: "We really should have been working on our chemistry
instead of having the backgrounds eat us alive."
But Monkeybone betrays him by stealing the exit pass
and going into Fraser's body in the real world,
resulting in the real Fraser being put away.
So like most boners, you think it's your friend,
but it often gets you in trouble and sometimes even lands you in prison.
So now Monkeybone is in Brendan Fraser's body.  Oh the possibilities this opens up.
I mean there's just so many defining character traits of Monkeybone.
Like: he's silly...
he's horny...
he likes to dress like Marilyn Monroe for some reason.
Honestly I'll probably get more character out of the peach from Selick's last movie than this.
So we have a not very defined character, now being portrayed by a not very defined actor.
Don't get me wrong, he's clearly trying.
He's jumping all over the place, and screaming and such.
But, again, that's kind of expected.
Nothing is really added to make it his own.
Even this spit take just seems run of the mill.
Come on, it's a spit take!
There has to be more life in it than that!
Part of what makes those work is the unexpectedness.
I don't even know where that came from!
It gets even more uncomfortable when Fonda tries to seduce him.
What a...peculiar way to seduce a man.
"This is what I call the PG-13."
Laughing yet?
Yeah, I think Fonda's look of horror speaks for all of us.
No, STOP SHOWING THAT.
This is not worth whatever impact you think it's having on us!
Dah!
Okay, I will die a happy ma-
a less angry ma-
I will not die if you never show me that again!
Oh thank God, one of those "Hulk" transitions finally had a good use.
Fraser is thrown in prison with a ton of crazy minds who create great nightmares.
Including Stephen King, who says Cujo stole his body like Monkeybone did when he was in a coma.
Stephen King: I went through hell to get that exit pass.
And who got to use it?  Cujo.
Yeah.  I always wondered why Stephen King's last five novels were just "Bark Bark Bark."
To make things weirder,
that's the actual Stephen King playing himself in the movie.
Okay, it's not.  But admit it, you were starting to IMDb that!
But Hypnos infiltrates Monkeybone's dream
to remind him this is all so he could spread more nightmares around the world.
Hypnos: We help him swipe your body, he helps us get a heap of brand new nightmares!
NC: That's right. This guy that had maybe three minutes of screen time, he's our villain now!
Oh there's so many complex motivations and personalities going on in this film!
Like:
why the hell Chuck E. Cheese
genetically melted into Barf the dog.
This movie's asking questions that didn't need to be asked.
So Monkeybone tries to find that nightmare juice
brought up before and force it on people
all over the world.
Okay, if that poncho is indicating that this is all a secret sequel to "Unbreakable,"
I am totally opting out of the Shyamalan cinematic universe!
Monkeybone/Stu: Why don't you give me a little preview.
NC: The writer of "Batman," everybody!
No! Seriously.
Sam Hamm, the guy who wrote "Batman" also wrote this.
Actually, I hate to say it, but it makes a little too much sense.
The villain wants to release a gas on everybody
disguised in a giant cartoon
while a sexy cat-woman
comes in suddenly deciding she's in love with the main character,
and McDonald's wants to attach their Happy Meal rights
to a franchise sure to have children wet their beds.
Maybe Keaton saved those movies more than I thought.
Give those movies credit though,
they didn't spend an entire NINETY SECONDS
congratulating themselves for a farting monkey doll.
Oh, and you guessed right!
I counted!
Just for that, you get the button.
*Explosion*
Monkeybone tests the nightmare juice on the pet dog,
giving him - what else - a nightmare.
Whoa, cat videos on the dark web
are creepier than I expected.
He puts the doll with the gas
inside a giant statue of his character, and...
*falsetto*
"Homie the Clown!"
That was the "Simpsons" episode
that had that Krusty frame.
God, it was driving me nuts.
Oh, and that scene sucked.
So, as mentioned, the cat-lady breaks Fraser out of prison
only to immediately be caught again.
They don't even show him being caught,
it's off screen.
So, why'd you have him escape at all?
(To the Rainbow Connection) :
♪Some day we'll find it.♪
♪The screenplay's connection,♪
♪The author's♪
♪intention♪
♪maybeeeee!♪
Reaper: I'm a simple person.
I do an honest day's work.
Why does everybody make it so hard for me?
NC: That is literally what Whoopi said every day of shooting.
Fraser's sob story wins her over though,
so she sends him back via SNL actor trying way to hard.
Stu: Where am I?
NC: In a shot that can crop out their mics better.
Chris Kattan is now playing our hero for a bit,
and to be fair his physical comedy is pretty good
playing a gymnast who's neck is broken,
so he has to keep finding ways to prop it up.
This bit's been done literally to death,
but he does pull it off okay.
I'm just waiting to see where the "Better Call Saul" storyline
is gonna fit in.
Saul: I...
NC: Meanwhile Foley gets a whiff of the nightmare juice
from the farting Monkeybone toy.
Herb (played by Foley): Damn, what the hell is this stuff?
NC: Oh look it's what Henry Selick said after every re-write.
He starts seeing his nightmares in real life,
because - let's face it -
this is all just an unused Freddy Krueger script.
Herb: Clothes have turned evil!
They're working together!
NC: You're really gonna regret that this was the film
you went naked for.
Oh excuse me, I almost interrupted the master.
Can I package your misdirection?
Monkeybone: Ladies and gentlemen...
forget about the naked man with the purple face.
*joke drums and laughter*
NC: Oh ho. That old joke.
But wait!
It's an early 2000's bad film, dance number time!
*Brick House by The Commodores is sung*
Oh you forgot the shadow of the camera man if he wanted to dance.
Before he continues to be DOA (dated on arrival),
Kattan literally swings his way in because...
even though it's supposed to be Fraser's mind in there,
he suddenly knows gymnastics.
I honestly give Kattan more credit though,
he does pull off the only believable bit of emotion in the movie.
Stu: I had to come back, Julie.
*sigh* I WAS happy Julie.
I really was.
Try to remember me like that...okay?
NC: He's giving a better Bendan Fraser performance than Brenden Fraser.
But Monkeybone tries to stop him through...
"Rat Races" greatest hits.
Though their greenscreen was more convincing
than the SPECIAL EFFECTS FILM.
And they both get sent back to Down Town.
*Whoopi making noises*
"I was just practicing my fake excitement for when I have to to 'Theodore Rex.'
Did it seem real?"
Monkeybone is left back in Fraser's mind,
he goes back to the real world
to be reunited with Fonda
trying to pretend she gives a shit,
and let's go out on what we know was the funniest part of the movie.
Herb: People...for the love of God!
Take off your clothes!
TAKE! OFF! YOUR CLOTHES!
"Monkeybone" is arguably the last of the dark, weird, wild, and crazy movies
that exists just to exist.
There's a good reason it's the last one though.
Because it's done horribly.
While the visuals and imagination are stunning,
the lack of focus on motivation, comedy, and even just fun are completely misdirected.
Thankfully this director would do more projects that were just as dark and imaginative,
but this time carry charm and intelligence along with it.
As would more weird and dark movies
that decide they wanted to be smarter too.
This just leaves you mentally numb.
Like a hot spatula pressing against your brain
for an hour and a half.
I'm glad other imaginative and likable ventures rose in the future,
but this was certainly not one of them.
Uncle Lies: Okay kids.  It's time to go home.
NC: W-wait. You're related to those kids then.
Uncle Lies: No.
Aunt Despair: Never seen 'em.
NC: I have to ask more questions around here.
*The Review Must Go On plays*
Monkeybone: OW-OW-OW. Where'd you dingdong?
Doug: Hey, this is Doug Walker doing the charity shoutout,
and this week we are doing Action against Hunger.
This is an international relief and development organization
committed to saving the lives of malnourished children and families
while providing substantial access to safe water
and long term solutions to hunger.
Recognized as a world leader in the fight against hunger,
they have pursued it's vision of a world without hunger
for nearly three decades.
Combating hunger in emergency situations of conflict,
natural disaster, and chronic food insecurity.
With headquarters in New York, London, Madrid, Montreal, and Paris,
their field staff work in over 40 countries
to carry out innovative and life saving programs
in nutrition, food security, water and sanitation,
health, and advocacy.
If you check out their site or their YouTube page,
you can see how their programs reach over 4 million people a year.
They do amazing work, and you can help them do even more.
Take a look, give a click, and see if you can help those who help others.